تصعيد متبادل بين شطرين شبه الجزيره
الكوريه على وقع مناورات العاصفه اليقظه
التي تنخرط فيها كوريا الجنوبيه مع
الولايات المتحده تتواصلوا مشاهد استعراض
القوه بين الكوريتين
المناورات التي تقررت تمديدها الى السبت
بسبب تصاعد التوتر هي الكبرى في تاريخ
العلاقات بين واشنطن التي اعلنت انها
تشارك بنحو 240 طائره حجم المناورات دفع
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الكوريه الشماليه
لدعوه واشنطن لطفها باعتبارها استفزازيه
هو الاستفزاز المتبادل اذا كما ان
المناورات تستفز الشطر الشمالي فللجنوب
ايضا ما يستفزه ويرقه يقول كوريا الجنوبيه
انها نشرت 80 مقاتله بعضها من طراز اف 35
اي ردا على ما قالت انها رصدته من تحليق
نحو 180 طائره حربيه كوريا الشماليه شمال
الحدود العسكريه على مدى اربع ساعات كما
اتهمت السل ليس الكوريه الشماليه باطلاق
نحو 80 قديفه مدفعيه على المنطقه الحدوديه
البحريه بين البلدين الهاجس الاكبر لكوريا
الجنوبيه وحلفائها ما اكدته السل من
النجاره الشمال اطلقت الخميس صاروخا
باليستيا عابرا للقارات قطع نحو 760 كلم
على ارتفاع
1920 كيلو مترا تقريبا رجحت هيئه الاركان
الكوريه الجنوبيه فشل العمليه لكن كوريا
الشماليه لا تتوقف عن تجارب الاطلاق تلك
التي بلغت مستوى قياسيا خلال العام الجاري
تقرا خطوات بيوم ديانج باعتبارها
استفزازات متكرره تستوجب الرد بتدابير
جديده هذا ما اكده وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن خلال لقائه بواشنطن نظيره
الكوري الجنوبي لجونسكو قال اوستن ان اليه
هجوم النووي على بلاده او حلفائها
وشركائها سيتسبب في نهايه نظام
مورانو
لم يكن امريكيا فقط بل جاء في بيان
لمجموعه السبع ان اي تجربه نوويه كوريه
شماليه او اي عمل طائش يجب ان يواجه برد
دولي سريع وموحد وقوي
حافه الانفجار التي تصل اليها تلك
التهديدات تقابلها مساعي تهدئه سياسيه
فواشنطن وفق تصريحات مسؤول رفيع بها
لرويترز ترغب في ان تستخدم الصين وروسيا
نفوذهما لاقناع كوريا الشماليه بعدم
استئناف تجارب القنبله النوويه بل ساعه
الولايات المتحده للتواصل مع كوريا
الشماليه عبر قنوات خاصه ومن خلال اطراف
ثالثه وفي الوقت نفسه تستكمل ترتيبات لعقد
قمه بين قاده الولايات المتحده واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه
منتصف الشهر الجاري ترفض الولايات المتحده
ان يتعامل المجتمع الدولي مع كوريا
الشماليه باعتبارها قوه نوويه ولتحقيق ذلك
تراوح بين خيارين الحراك السياسي والتلويح
بالقوه العسكريه مستثمره تحالفاتها مع
جيران جيونغ الاقربين